bonjour talent vous suivez évidemment
ces scrutins les bureaux de vote ont
ouvert ce matin
oui cette grande consultation populaire
aurait dû à la base se tenir le 22 avril
dernier mais voilà le coronavirus est
passée par là résultat le scrutin a donc
été repoussé deux 2 mois il va se tenir
sur une semaine au lieu de se tenir
uniquement dans la journée du 1er
juillet et les modalités de
participation ont elles aussi également
évolué ainsi jusqu'au 1er juillet les
citoyens de russie auront la possibilité
de voter depuis chez eux soit par vote
électronique pour certains par courrier
ou encore on se rendant dans leur bureau
de vote de façon classique comme pour
les autres scrutins
mais au fait de quel changement à la
constitution on parle exactement la
plupart des médias se sont concentrés
sur les changements qui permettrait à
vladmir poutine de briguer deux mandats
supplémentaires ou encore sur
l'inscription dans la constitution du
mariage en tant que union entre un homme
et une femme mais ce n'est pas ce qui
intéresse le plus les russes un récent
sondage montre que leur priorité se
porte davantage sur la garantie de
l'accès aux soins médicaux ou encore
l'inscription dans la constitution des
enfants en tant que priorité des
politiques publiques
les derniers sondages montrent qu entre
67 et 71 % de ceux qui vont voter se
prononceront en faveur de ces
amendements constitutionnels mais c'est
bien là participé à la participation qui
sera scruté de très près c'est ça qui
permettra de juger
l'engouement pour cette réforme
constitutionnelle merci beaucoup en tant
que l'hérault depuis moscou